on va parler d'un tout autre sujet c'est
lors de notre reportage à votre
rencontre dans les pyrénées le débat
entre pro et anti ours au pot 2 les
habitants depuis que l'état réintroduit
le prédateur dans les années 90 il vient
de s'enflammer de plus belle après la
taxe d'un chasseur par une ourse pendant
une battue c'était le 20 novembre entre
partisans la biodiversité et acteurs du
territoire qui se sentent menacés le
dialogue est rompu en garde ce reportage
en ariège il est signé fabien à coeur à
la frontière de l'ariège et de la haute
garonne le village d'arbas et le fief
des défenseurs de l'ours dans les
pyrénées c'est ici que trois ours ont
été lâchés en 2006 et dans la vallée
qu'on peut voir juste ici en face à nous
si la météo le permet alain reynes a
fondée ici l'association pays de l'ours
qui défend la présence du prédateur dans
ces vallées on voit que maintenant on a
une continuité sur depuis l'ariège
jusqu'aux pyrénées atlantiques de la
présence de lourches depuis le 20
novembre le débat entre pro et anti ours
est reparti de plus belle
ce jour-là un chasseur a été attaqué par
une ourse selon l'association il
pourrait s'agir de caramel films est ici
avec ses oursons gravement blessé aux
jambes le chasseur a abattu l'animal
c'est quelque chose qu'on cherche à
éviter qu'on cherche à limiter au
maximum le risque qu'ils aient jamais
nulle salle au risque quand on va en
montagne il est jamais venu et
malheureusement chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités pour effectivement
limiter au maximum ces risques puisque
de toute façon on ne peut pas l'éviter
les ours sont là resteront là les
chasseurs sont là et ils resteront là
également donc la seule issue possible
c'est la cohabitation mais pour ces
chasseurs la cohabitation est impossible
et tant pis si la justice a depuis
ouvert une enquête indiquant que la
chasse était interdite sur le lieu de
l'attaqué du 20 novembre ce jour là ils
sont venus de tout le département à
l'appel des élus locaux pour proclamer
le parlement à venir montagne ou éviter
les accidents ce sont les hommes qui
devront partir ou ce qu'elle veut et et
survivre plutôt que vivement
l'association réunit le conseil
départemental la chambre d'agriculture
et la fédération pastorale ensemble ces
acteurs du territoire veulent mettre la
pression sur l'état on attend un acte
fort là là sur une question de
régulation sur une question de retrait
parce qu'on veut pas laisser les gens
avec un endroit où
le territoire serait colonisée par les
ours et les hommes en seraient car pour
ces opposants à l'ours c'est bien
l'avenir des activités humaines en
montagne qui est menacée
devenu dangereux pour l'homme des pans
entiers du territoire serait condamnée à
terme à la désertification la
cohabitation ne marche pas défaut il ya
25 ans en colombie les mesures de
protection il ya juste besoin de temps
que la comco les met en place des chiens
des parcs des dépenses aux conditions
d'énergie supplémentaire des low cost je
ne fais que livré un constat c'est que
le constat c'est que ça ne marche pas
voilà aujourd'hui les jours s'attaque
aux dans les parcs les sources atraco
l'héberger pourtant même au sein du
monde pastoral le sujet divise
éleveurs et bergers miguel barbosa
brunet vient de rentrer sa centaine de
chèvres et de brebis pour l'hiver elles
vont être confiné la
décembre janvier février
fin mars au sein de son groupement
d'éleveurs adversaires et partisans de
l'ours travailler ensemble pour miguel
la cohabitation avec le prédateur est
possible grâce aux moyens de protection
ça c'est c'est le montagner pyrénées dit
le patou sceller les siens
qui servent de moyen
pour
10 soit des déprédations une fois que le
berger a fait sa journée
de garde avec les bêtes ils rentrent le
soir
dans un parc de préférence pas trop loin
de la cabane avec les patrons au milieu
et
voilà son tour et dans un parc
électrifié quoi mais le discours de
miguel est loin d'être majoritaire en
ariège où la fédération pastorale avance
le chiffre de 600 brebis tuées par
l'ours cet été l'état vient de nommer un
préfet délégué à l'ours en occitanie
pour tenter de trouver des solutions et
d'apaiser les tensions et pour en parler
nous rejoindre
avec le chef adjoint de la dépêche du
midi vous suivez bien sûr
particulièrement la dépêche du midi ce
dossier d'abord première question eric
on le chasseur a été attaqué par une
hausse il ya quelques jours qu'elle et
son état de santé aujourd'hui
est bien le chasseur on est toujours
hospitalisé
dans la région ce ses jours ne sont pas
en danger mais bon il ya vraiment eu
beaucoup de chance parce qu'il a été
mordu à la jambe et il a été secouru en
fait par une pompiers volontaires qui se
trouvait dans la battue qui était
organisée ce jour-là une battue au
sanglier
malheureusement il a dû tirer pour se
défendre en direction de l'ours qui qui
est décédé en tout cas comme vous l'avez
noté dans ce reportage ça rouvre
vraiment le débat entre pro et anti ours
et on voit bien que les deux points de
vue sont difficiles à réconcilier vous
savez c'est un sujet dont on parle très
très régulièrement dans nos colonnes ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'il ya un
tel incident alors jamais aussi grave
avec la mort de l'ours mais on avait eu
au début du mois d'août un éleveur qui
avait été poursuivi par un ours et puis
il ya quelques mois on avait raconté la
mésaventure survenue un randonneur qui
lui aussi avait été
pourchassé par un plantigrade
voyez les incidents arrivent il serait
même de plus en plus nombreux selon les
éleveurs et les chasseurs qui la semaine
dernière manifesté et réclamé que des
abattages soit ont réalisé sur sur des
ours ceux considérés comme les plus
menaçants et puis comme évoqué dans
votre reportage mais aussi dans nos
colonnes les pro ours estime que la
cohabitation est possible et que
finalement il n'y aurait pas tant
d'incidents que cela et en prenant
certaines mesures on peut protéger les
élevages il faut savoir qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une soixantaine d'ours dans
les pyrénées
et il y en aurait près d'une quarantaine
dans ce secteur du couserans en ariège
et puis dernier élément il ya quand même
une enquête judiciaire qui est ouverte
suite à cet incident survenu il ya une
dizaine de jours et la procureure de la
république de foix a annoncé vendredi
une information judiciaire était ouverte
pour destruction d'espèce protégée mais
aussi chasse sur un secteur non autorisé
ce qui a fait hurler les chasseurs qui
estime avoir eu toutes les autorisations
préfectorales pour faire cette cette
battue au sanglier avec nous avait donné
beaucoup d'informations à venir
pour parler de ce sujet peut-être un mot
clément avec vous on voit on l'a vu dans
le reportage est avec nous en a parlé il
ya les pros il ya les entiers difficile
pour un possible de concilier les points
de vue oui ça fait partie des débats qui
sont où les clivages sont telles qu'on
n'arrivera pas à réconcilier à
réconcilier les parties autour de la
table la même manière sur le sur le loup
d'ailleurs aussi
après ce qu on peut quand même
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a réintroduit
l'ours déjà on se serait attendu lourd
s'en souvenir ce qui était un tour c'est
pourquoi pendant des siècles on l'avait
chassé
j'ai le sentiment je suis tout à fait
ouvert à d'autres informations là-dessus
mais qu'on l'a réintroduit pour rétablir
un état de nature parce qu'on l'avait
finalement
abattu où on l'avait trop chasser il en
avait plus on l'a rétabli pour rétablir
cet état mais est ce qu'il ya vraiment
une utilité à la biodiversité en fait
pourquoi avoir réintroduit l'ours c'est
une vraie question moi j'entends pas
beaucoup de réponses là dessus on
n'entend pas beaucoup des écolos
finalement défendre et justifier cette
réintroduction outre que le
rétablissement de la nature donc j'aime
l'ambiance et en plus
c'est un des vrais débats du moment
c'est à dire voilà l'homme
historiquement a cherché à domestiquer
la nature à la maîtrise et à l'ab à s'en
protéger
on a aussi des enjeux liés à la
biodiversité qui mobilise de plus en
plus l'attention des points de friction
entre les deux parfois on compte sur la
technologie comme une espèce de avec des
effaroucheurs de moyens de protection
etc mais au fond que me disait clément
il ya un vrai débat sur notre rapport à
la nature qui est qui posait pour ce
sujet là comme bien d'autres
juste un mot sur les chasseurs cet
épisode d' attaque d'un chasseur par
l'ours il intervient dans un contexte on
est en pleine campagne présidentielle et
les chasseurs ça représente 1 million
d'électeurs ils sont très écoutées en ce
moment et d'ailleurs il il faut apporter
leur voix ils demandent d'avoir une
police de chasseurs dans les campagnes
également qu'on préserve les chasses
traditionnelles donc ils ont une voix
qui pèsent sur ce moment oui
effectivement puisqu'on parlait du débat
des questions qui se posent autour de la
réintroduction des ours est ce que du
coup c'est un débat qui relançait
fallait-il ou non réintroduire l'ours
qui a été réintroduit par l'homme
oui effectivement c'est la question de
fond
savoir aussi c'était vraiment nécessaire
parce qu'on essaie de finalement de
faire cohabiter cet animal avec
l'activité humaine dans les montagnes de
l'élevage il ya des villages il ya de la
randonnée en été est ce que c'était
vraiment nécessaire de réintroduire
l'animal est ce que la cohabitation est
possible on voit qu'il ya des incidents
aujourd'hui l'état est assez discret sur
la question de réintroduire d'autres
sources parce que donc il ya cet ours
qui a été abattu mais il ya eu trois
autres courses qui ont été retrouvés
morts visiblement eux aussi à cause de
tirs au cours des derniers mois ça
ferait donc quatre ours qui ferait
peut-être remplacer on voit bien que les
élus au niveau national soit assez gêné
aux entournures et évite en ce moment de
prendre position sur cette question
vraiment kitty qui les donne lieu à un
vif très vifs débats
particulièrement la dépêche du midi on a
parlé aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui dont on
aurait évidemment l'occasion de parler
avec vous
[Musique]